une situation qui paraît presque
irréelle la nuit du 4 au 5 comme celle
du 1er au 2 novembre les portes des
urgences de l'hôpital de laval sont
restées closes pour sept représentants
du personnel aide soignante dans le
service concerné la cause est toujours
la même quand un urgentiste prend sa
garde à 8h30 le matin il arrive parfois
avec 15 patients qui sont présents dans
le couloir des urgences depuis la veille
donc soit 12 à 24 heures pour certains
patients qui reste sur des brancards ou
sur des lits qui sont sur des brancards
transformer en lit par manque de lits
dans les services et donc de vie dans
les services par manque d'effectifs
médicaux au total une centaine de
personnels aux urgences pour une
centaine de passages par jour
insuffisant d'après la chef du service
dans une situation catastrophique au
niveau des effectifs médicaux on est
cinq équivalents temps plein pour une
cible entre 16 et 18 donc on peut pas
faire fonctionner le planning
correctement donc on a été obligé pour
la première fois dans l'histoire des
urgences de laval de fermer la nuit la
nuit du 1er au 2 et puis la nuit qui
vient de se finir on affirmer aussi pour
elle trois points sont à revoir le flux
d'amont qui correspond à l'arrivée des
patients aux urgences les déserts
médicaux contraignent les malades à se
rendre aux urgences faute de médecins et
engorgent les services il faudrait selon
elle que les patients puissent être
prise en charge avant les urgences
également en cause l'environnement au
travail le personnel médical exercent
souvent dans des conditions difficiles
et beaucoup partent ou abandonnent leurs
activités enfin troisième point crucial
le flux d'aval il faudrait d'après les
professionnels de santé plus de lits
pour hospitaliser correctement les
patients la mise en place de la réserve
sanitaire ne compense pas le manque de
médecins et pour l'association de
citoyens contre les déserts médicaux
cette situation n'est pas un hasard le
constat c'est que déjà on a non médecins
qui sont actuellement en activité qui
vont arriver à la retraite et pour une
bonne partie qui sont bons à la retraite
qu'à l'heure actuelle si ma mémoire est
bonne il doit y avoir à peu près quatre
à cinq mille citoyens mayennais
notamment lavallois qui n'ont plus de
médecins traitants faut savoir ce qu'on
e où on veut sauver la peau poignet la
population ou alors on s'en fout
contactée par téléphone la direction de
l'hôpital a préféré ne pas répondre à
nos sollicitations
évoquant notamment son devoir de réserve
cette nuit les urgences seront à nouveau
fermées